Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. I'm joined by Dr. Ali Matu, a clinical psychologist at the Columbia University Center for Anxiety and Related Disorders. He's also the host of a YouTube series called The Psych Show, where he's been explaining psychological concepts and giving advice to his more than 15,000 subscribers for more than three years now. Welcome, Dr. Matu. Thanks for having me. Okay, so you have your PhD. You have a great job. You're a psychologist.
大家好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是由美国心理学协会制作的一档播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。今天和我在一起的是阿里·马图博士（Dr. Ali Matu），他是哥伦比亚大学焦虑与相关障碍中心的临床心理学家。他还是一个名为“心理学秀”（The Psych Show）的YouTube系列节目的主持人。三年多来，他一直在该节目中向其15,000多名订阅者解释心理学概念并提供建议。欢迎你，马图博士。谢谢你邀请我。好的，你有博士学位。你有一份很棒的工作。你是一名心理学家。
So what brought you to wanting to do these videos online? What made you want to start your channel? I was sitting with a patient of mine back in 2014, and they said, Ali, can I share with you this video that's been really helpful for me? It's kind of changed my life. It's really helped me to understand things in any way. And I said, yeah, sure, let's watch.
那么是什么让你想要在网上制作这些视频呢？是什么让你萌生了开通频道的想法？2014年的时候，我和我的一个病人坐在一起，她说：“阿里，我能跟你分享一个对我有很大帮助的视频吗？它有点改变了我的生活。它确实在很大程度上帮我理解了一些事情。”我说：“行啊，当然可以，我们来看看。”
it was a YouTube video. It was some YouTuber, I think a teenager that was sharing their advice, and it was like completely wrong. It was like completely wrong advice. It was not what any psychologist would say. And so I told her, I said, I told my patient, give me a moment, let me find something that's like more effective, more true to the science, and I couldn't find anything. And that put me down a path of trying to find, trying to find out where all the psychologists, YouTubers were. I couldn't really find any. And then I decided I have to do something about that. I have to change that. So why do you think people need psychology brought to them? And in a way, like a YouTube channel, as opposed to going to see a psychologist in an office?
那是一个YouTube视频。是某个视频博主，我猜是个青少年，在分享他们的建议，但内容完全是错的。那完全是错误的建议，根本不是任何一个心理学家会说的话。所以我告诉她，我告诉我的病人：“等一下，让我找一些更有效、更符合科学的东西。”但我什么也没找到。这让我踏上了一条寻找之旅——试图找出所有的心理学家博主都在哪里。我基本上没找到什么。然后我决定我必须为此做点什么。我必须改变这种状况。那么，你认为为什么人们需要接触心理学？为什么人们需要通过YouTube频道这样的方式，而不是去办公室看心理学家？
Well, psychology is so relevant to everything. There aren't. really any areas of life where human behavior, mental process, emotions, all of these things are not applicable. And so as a result of that, people are having conversations about psychology all the time in every medium. And if we aren't a part of those conversations, if the field of psychology, if experts in psychology aren't a part of those conversations, they happen regardless, without us. And so what that means is we...
嗯，心理学与一切都息息相关。几乎没有任何生活领域是人类行为、心理过程、情绪这些东西不适用的。因此，人们随时随地都在各个媒介上讨论心理学。如果我们不参与这些讨论，如果心理学界、心理学专家不参与这些讨论，它们也会照常发生，而没有我们的参与。这意味着……
We can't share our knowledge, our experience with the public. The public's going to have these conversations and who knows if they're based in real science or not. So there was a former APA president who gave a speech about giving psychology away about 50 years ago. And in that speech you talked about how there will never be enough psychologists to meet the demands of the world. And we can't be in every place and every time and do everything that's needed of us. So what we have to do is give psychology away to other people so that they can use it in their organizations, with their families, with their friends, so that they can become their own psychologists. And that idea has really resonated with me. And that's one of the reasons
我们无法与公众分享我们的知识和经验。公众仍然会进行这些讨论，而且谁知道它们是否有真正的科学依据呢？大约50年前，美国心理学协会（APA）的一位前会长曾发表过一篇关于“普及心理学”（giving psychology away）的演讲。在那次演讲中，你谈到将永远没有足够多的心理学家来满足世界的需求。我们不可能在任何地方、任何时间都做到一切所需之事。所以我们必须做的是，把心理学交给其他人，让他们能够在自己的组织中、与家人和朋友一起使用它，这样他们就能成为自己的心理学家。这个想法深深地引起了我的共鸣。这也是其中一个原因。
why I started my channel is just to try to give all this information away on a platform where there weren't really other psychologists doing that. So communicating psychology to a non-scientific audience is something you've been doing for a long time now. Can you explain how you've been kind of prepping for this moment? Yeah, so we've got to go way back. I wasn't really a good student growing up. I was really into science fiction. I like riding my bike.
我开通频道的初衷，就是试图在一个当时几乎没有其他心理学家这样做的平台上，免费分享所有这些信息。所以，向非专业受众传播心理学，这件你一直在做的事已经有一段时间了。你能解释一下你是如何为这一刻做准备的吗？是的，我们要把时间追溯到很久以前。我上学的时候其实并不是个好学生。我非常迷恋科幻小说。我喜欢骑自行车。
I like climbing trees, and that was about it. So I kind of barely passed high school. I got rejected from every college I applied to. And I ended up going to community college, and just by chance, the first class I enrolled in was introductory psychology. And I sat in the back of the classroom with a hoodie on not that far away from here. I grew up in the Bay Area and went to community college out there in Cupertino, California. and it was the introductory psychology class
我喜欢爬树，差不多就这些。所以我的高中可以说是勉强及格。我申请的每一所大学都拒绝了我。最后我去了社区大学，机缘巧合之下，我选的第一门课就是心理学导论。我穿着连帽衫坐在教室的最后一排，离这里不远。我在湾区长大，并去加州库比蒂诺的社区大学就读。那是心理学导论课。
and that first lecture blew me away. It was all about the myths we have about psychology and what's true and what's not and everything I believed about the brain about human behavior was wrong and this class kind of opened my eyes to it. And the more I took the class, the more I realized that all those ideas,
第一堂讲座让我大开眼界。内容全是关于我们对心理学的种种迷思、什么是真的、什么是假的，我对大脑和人类行为的种种坚信不疑的想法全都是错的，而这门课让我大开眼界。我上这门课越多，就越意识到所有的这些想法——
those science fiction stories that I was fascinated by, it was because they raised these big questions about who we are. And here's a science that has answers to those questions. Why are people good? What are the forces that might lead people to do bad things? How can we grow as a species? How can we help each other? So I ended up becoming a psychologist to make a long story short. After I finished my degree and my training, I wanted to weave those things together, psychology and science fiction. So I started a blog where, I talked about all of that stuff.
那些让我着迷的科幻故事，正是因为它们提出了关于“我们是谁”的宏大问题。而这里有一门科学，它对这些问题有着答案。为什么人们会是好人？是什么力量导致人们做坏事？我们作为一个物种该如何成长？我们该如何互相帮助？长话短说，我最终成为了一名心理学家。在我完成学位和培训后，我想把这两样东西交织在一起：心理学和科幻小说。于是我创办了一个博客，在上面谈论所有这些内容。
And for me, it's always been thinking about that middle school kid who was bad at school, thought he was dumb, was depressed, and trying to create content that's going to reach out to kids like me, or kids like who I was, and help them discover, understand psychology, maybe use it to improve their life in some way. Because I always wonder what would have happened had I discovered psychology when I was in middle school. Would it put my path in a different, or would it put my life down a different path? So I've been trying to create content that I would have wanted when I was younger, and that might have helped me discover, use love psychology.
对我来说，我总是想着那个在学校表现不好、觉得自己很笨、患有抑郁症的中学男生，并努力创作能够触及像我这样的孩子、或者像我过去那样的孩子的内容，帮助他们发现、理解心理学，或许还能用它在某种程度上改善他们的生活。因为我总是在想，如果我在中学时就发现了心理学会怎么样呢？这会不会让我的人生走上一条不同的道路？所以我一直在尝试创作我年轻时会希望看到的、可能曾帮助我发现并热爱心理学的内容。
So I started that blog, and through that writing, I discovered I was a really bad writer for the public. Like, psychology grad school teaches us very well in regards to thinking like a psychologist and communicating with other psychologists. Psychology doesn't really do a good job of teaching us how to communicate with non-psychologists. Those of you who've gotten involved in teaching, you probably realize that in your first class. I love teaching, but my first class, I'll never forget the student Eval that said, this man should never be allowed to teach another psychology class ever again. I remember verbatim, it's like ingrained in my mind. Because I wasn't a good teacher, and when I started that blog, I realized I really struggled
所以我创办了那个博客，通过那段写作经历，我发现自己其实是一个很不擅长为公众写作的人。比如，心理学研究生院教会了我们如何像心理学家一样思考以及如何与其他心理学家沟通。但心理学并没有很好地教我们如何与非心理学家沟通。在座各位凡是从事过教学工作的人，可能在你们的第一堂课上就意识到了这一点。我热爱教学，但我的第一堂课，我永远不会忘记那个学生的评价，他说：“绝对不应该再允许这个人教任何心理学课程了。”我至今仍一字不差地记得，它已经深深地烙印在我的脑海里。因为我当时不是个好老师，当我开始写那个博客时，我意识到我真的很挣扎。
to communicate psychology with a non-psychology audience. I used a lot of jargon. My articles were probably about three times the length they should be, because I felt like that's what we do in psychology. We write, like, thousands of words, and that's what makes it a good article. I also buried the lead. So the most important, most relevant part of my writing
难以用非心理学受众能听懂的方式去传播心理学。我用了大量的专业术语。我的文章大概是我应该写的三倍长度，因为我觉得这就是我们在心理学领域所做的事情。我们动辄写下成千上万个字，而这就是一篇好文章的标志。我还把重点藏在了后面。所以我的文章中最重要、最相关的部分——
came, like, six, seven paragraphs in. Because that's what you do when you write an intro section for a paper. Like, your hypothesis, that big question you have, the thing you're investigating, it's like at the end of your intro section. Journalists, they flip it. It's the very first most important part of the whole thing that you're writing is that first sentence. So I got a lot of feedback from a lot of people.
到了第六、第七段才出现。因为当你为论文写引言部分时，你就是这么做的。比如你的假设、你提出的那个宏大问题、你正在调查的事物，往往都在引言部分的末尾。但记者们的做法完全相反。他们会把最重要、最核心的东西放在最开头，整篇文章写的第一个句子就是全篇最重要的部分。所以我从很多人那里得到了很多反馈。
A friend of mine is a writer, and he took me aside and said, can we talk about your writing? Because it's really bad. So he taught me a lot about how to write for a non-psychology audience. And then after that, I started a podcast with a good friend of mine. And that podcast taught me how to build an audience. And then I had that patient who shared that YouTube video with me, and I was like, okay, I need to bring this stuff together.
我的一个朋友是作家，他把我拉到一边对我说：“我们能谈谈你的写作吗？因为实在太糟糕了。”于是他教了我很多关于如何为非心理学受众写作的技巧。在那之后，我和一个好朋友创办了一档播客。那档播客教会了我如何建立受众群体。然后，我就遇到了那个跟我分享YouTube视频的病人，当时我想：好吧，我需要把这些东西结合起来。
Maybe I'll experiment with the YouTube channel. So how did you go from those ideas, and so from the blog to the podcast, the video? How did you get from that idea to making it happen? I mean, that involved equipment, ideas coming up with kind of a storyboard of sorts. I looked at up videos on YouTube. Yeah, about how to create a YouTube video. I said, like, how do you start a YouTube channel?
也许我该在YouTube频道上做个实验。那么你是如何从那些想法——从博客到播客，再到视频？你是如何从那个想法付诸实践的呢？我的意思是，这需要设备、各种想法，还要想出某种类似分镜头脚本的东西。我在YouTube上搜索了相关视频。是的，关于如何制作YouTube视频的视频。我说：“怎么开设一个YouTube频道？”
And I watched those videos. And then I looked at videos, what camera should I get if I'm starting a YouTube channel? And I watched those videos. How do I light a YouTube video? And I learned about a three light setup. It was a lot of trial and error. And one of the other things I learned over time is YouTube is very different than TV or film production. As long as you have content that is connecting with an audience
然后我观看了那些视频。接着我看了看：如果我要开通一个YouTube频道，应该买什么相机？我也看了那些视频。我该如何为YouTube视频打光？于是我了解了“三点布光法”。这其中包含了很多试错。随着时间的推移，我学到的另一件事是，YouTube与电视或电影制作非常不同。只要你的内容能够与观众产生共鸣——
and it's giving away something of value to them, either you're teaching them something or you're providing them with entertainment or you're creating content that's validating to a shared experience, that will find an audience. It doesn't have to be perfectly lit. You don't have to have perfect audio because the origins of YouTube are just people making videos in their bedrooms.
并且能为他们提供有价值的东西，要么你在教他们一些东西，要么你为他们提供娱乐，要么你创作的内容能够验证某种共同的经历，它就会找到它的受众。它不需要完美的光照。你不需要完美的音频，因为YouTube的起源本来就是人们在卧室里制作视频。
They don't have to be perfect. So I learned on YouTube and I also learned that it's a work in progress. My favorite thing to do on anyone's YouTube channel is click on videos and then click sort by oldest first
它们不需要完美。所以我通过YouTube进行了学习，我也了解到这是一个不断完善的过程。我在任何人的YouTube频道上最喜欢做的一件事，就是点击视频，然后选择“按最早发布排序”。
and it shows you their first few videos and they're always horrible. Go to your favorite YouTube channel. A channel has millions of subscribers, watch their first few videos and it's unrecognizable compared to where they are So the beauty of YouTube is you can see the growth of people how they've learned, how they've changed their content, how they've figured out who they are and what they want to communicate.
它会展示他们最初的几个视频，那些视频总是糟糕透顶。去看看你最喜欢的YouTube频道吧。一个拥有数百万订阅者的频道，看看他们最初的几个视频，与他们现在的水平相比简直面目全非。所以YouTube的魅力在于，你可以看到人们的成长，看到他们是如何学习的、如何改变内容的、如何弄清楚自己是谁以及他们想要传达什么。
So I just learned by trying. That's not to say it was like a perfect launch. I had a panic attack, like I treat anxiety. I know what a panic attack is. I had a panic attack. My first video that I was filming. I set up everything. It took about three hours to figure out how to set up lights, how to set up a camera, all of that sort of stuff.
所以我通过不断尝试来学习。这并不是说这是一个完美的开端。我当时恐慌发作了——就像我治疗焦虑症一样，我知道什么是恐慌发作。我确实恐慌发作了。那是我正在拍摄的第一个视频。我把一切都设置好了。光是琢磨怎么摆放灯光、怎么设置相机之类的事情，就花了大约三个小时。
And then I started to press, I pressed the record button and then turned on and then like the camera turned off. And the battery died. Apparently I had left the camera on for like three hours and the battery was dead. And I started sweating and shaking and my heart was racing. And then I eventually just like started crying. I'm like, what have I gotten myself into? So I never made that mistake again, though. Like you learn.
然后我开始按，我按下了录制键，然后开始录制，接着——相机突然关机了。电池没电了。显然我把相机开着大约三个小时，结果电池耗尽了。我开始出汗、发抖，心跳加速。最后我甚至直接哭了出来。我想：“我到底卷入了什么事情？”不过，从那以后我再也没有犯过那种错误。你会吸取教训。
You try, you make mistakes, you learn, you get feedback, you grow, you improve, you get better. And on your show, you give advice to people who might be experiencing anxiety, depression, dealing with phobias. Yeah. So how do you balance the desire and the need to give advice to you with some ethical considerations of the field? Yeah. So in addition to learning how to launch a YouTube channel, the other thing I was very conscious of learning was how to do this ethically. And I consulted with some folks.
你去尝试，你犯错误，你吸取教训，你得到反馈，你成长，你进步，你变得更好。在你的节目中，你为可能正在经历焦虑、抑郁、应对恐惧症的人们提供建议。是的。那么，你如何在为人们提供建议的愿望和需求，与该领域的道德考量之间找到平衡呢？是的。所以，除了学习如何开设YouTube频道之外，我非常清醒地意识到的另一件事，就是如何合乎道德地做到这一点。为此，我咨询了一些相关人士。
I read through the ethics code. And there is a paragraph about media presentations as a psychologist. And the gist of that is when you are acting in a professional role as a psychologist with the media, you're really accountable for what you say. So you want to make sure that what you're saying is based on your competencies, what you know, resonates with what we know in research and the science, and that it's not introducing any new relationship conflict. So there aren't like dual relationships that are being established,
我通读了道德规范准则。其中有一个段落是关于心理学家在媒体上进行演讲的。其核心意思是，当你以心理学家的专业角色在媒体中发言时，你必须为你所说的话承担真正的责任。所以你要确保你所说的话是基于你的专业胜任力、你所了解的知识，并且与我们在研究和科学中已知的知识相吻合，同时它没有引入任何新的关系冲突。也就是说，不会建立起双重关系——
all of that sort of stuff. So the way I digested that was every video I make, I need to know what I'm talking about. So anxiety, that's what I treat. I talk a lot about anxiety. I treat a lot of depression. But I haven't made a video on eating disorders because I really don't understand that stuff that well. And there's a lot of topics that I stay away from because I don't really, I can't speak to them easily. And maybe I'll have to do a lot of research to get up to speed on that,
诸如此类的各种事情。所以我对这一点的理解是：我制作的每一个视频，我都必须清楚自己在谈论什么。比如焦虑症，那正是我所治疗的领域。我谈论了很多关于焦虑症的话题。我也治疗过很多抑郁症患者。但我没有制作过关于进食障碍的视频，因为我对这方面的了解真的没有那么透彻。有很多话题是我刻意避开的，因为我真的不了解，我无法轻松地谈论它们。也许我需要做大量的研究才能赶上进度，
and it's just not going to make for a good video. So I try really hard to make sure everything I create is based on what I know. And then in terms of dual relationships, I don't really promote my channel with the patience I see. Sometimes I'm working with someone, and they're dealing with an issue that is covered by a video I've made. So sometimes I do share that video. with them, but I also tell them you're under no obligation to follow, like, or subscribe,
但这并不会成为一个好视频。所以我非常努力地确保我创作的一切都基于我所熟知的领域。至于双重关系，我其实并不会向我接待的病人宣传我的频道。有时我正在与某人合作，而他们正在处理的问题恰好被我制作的一个视频所涵盖。所以有时我确实会把那个视频分享给他们，但我也会告诉他们，你们没有任何义务去关注、点赞、订阅，
or comment to any video I create. And so I try to keep that distinction there. So that's kind of what I do. Make sure I know what I'm talking about. And make sure it doesn't get in the way of the work I do with any of my patients or my students that I teach or any of the other professional stuff that I do. And so now that you've had three years of content, what is your most memorable episode that you've done?
或者评论我制作的任何视频。所以我努力保持这种界限。这就是我一直在做的事情：确保我知道自己在谈论什么，并确保它不会妨碍我与任何病人、我教的学生或我从事的其他专业工作产生冲突。既然你已经积累了三年的内容，你做过的最难忘的一集是什么？
Well, there's a lot. There's a few that come to mind. So about six months into starting my YouTube channel, I was really unhappy with my views. And that's one of the things I hate about YouTube is there's so much analytical data. I can know exactly which videos are retaining viewers. YouTube gives me a graph of every video.
哦，有很多。有几个浮现在脑海里。在我开始经营YouTube频道的头六个月左右，我对自己的播放量非常不满意。这也是我讨厌YouTube的地方之一，那就是有太多的分析数据了。我可以确切地知道哪些视频留住了观众。YouTube为我提供了每个视频的图表。
And I know when people are clicking out, when a video isn't resonating with them, I know how the video is doing compared to, like, past videos I've made. And, like, if you're anyone who has, like, any sense of imposter syndrome, which is probably everyone in this exhibit hall, because that's what grad school does, it breeds this imposter syndrome. You can find other YouTube channels that have more views and more counts and all that sort of stuff that are, like, doing better than you. So six months in, I felt like I was such a failure,
我知道人们在什么时候点开、在什么时候视频没能引起他们的共鸣，我也知道这个视频的表现与我过去制作的视频相比如何。如果你有任何程度的“冒名顶替综合征”——展厅里的各位大概所有人都有，因为研究生院就是这样的地方，它滋生了这种冒名顶替综合征。你可以找到其他拥有更多播放量、更多粉丝数量等等、表现比你更好的YouTube频道。所以在运营六个月后，我觉得自己是个彻头彻尾的失败者，
and I wanted to do something big that would attract a huge audience. And so Star Wars Day was coming out, May the Fourth, as in May the Fourth be with you. And so I wanted to do a Star Wars episode. This is also before the new Star Wars movies came out, so there was more attention that was coming. So I bought a green screen.
我想要做一件大事来吸引大量的观众。当时“星球大战日”快到了，也就是5月4日（注：英文May the Fourth与星球大战经典台词May the Force be with you发音相似）。所以我想制作一集《星球大战》主题的节目。这也是在新的《星球大战》电影上映之前，所以当时会受到更多的关注。于是我买了一个绿幕。
I live in New York City, and no taxi cab would take me home with this nine-foot-long green screen that I brought. So I just lugged it into the subway in rush hour, And so, like, there was no room on the subway. Everyone was trying to crowd around my green screen. Went home. I created this Princess Leia wig using string.
我住在纽约市，没有一辆出租车愿意让我带着这个九英尺长的绿幕回家。所以我只能在交通高峰期把它硬拖进地铁里。当时地铁里根本没有空间。每个人都试图挤在我的绿幕周围。回到家后，我用绳子做了一个莱娅公主（Princess Leia）的假发。
I got my friend who also had a YouTube channel to come over. She dressed up as Han Solo. I dressed up as Princess Leia. It was, like, the most expensive video I've ever done. And it was really hard, and I made this whole video about Han Solo and the psychology of happiness and all of that. Took a lot of time to edit because I had to figure out how to make a green screen. And then like no one watched it.
我找了一个也有YouTube频道的朋友过来。她扮成汉·索罗（Han Solo）。我扮成莱娅公主。这可以说是我有史以来制作过成本最高的视频。而且过程非常艰难，我制作了整段关于汉·索罗和幸福心理学之类的视频。花了很多时间剪辑，因为我不得不琢磨怎么用绿幕。然后——几乎没有人看。
Like no one watched it. It's one of my worst performing videos I've ever made. And so with that, it's memorable because it taught me an important lesson. It's not about production value. It's not about the gimmicks. It's not about the costumes or the props or any of that sort of stuff. That's what all, everything I was chasing after. But it's about creating content that helps people.
就像根本没人看一样。这是我制作过表现最差的视频之一。因此，这件事之所以难忘，是因为它给我上了一个重要的一课。这与制作价值无关。这与噱头无关。这与服装、道具或任何类似的东西无关。那正是我一直在追逐的一切。真正重要的是创作能真正帮助人们的内容。
No one was searching for content related to Han Solo and the psychology of Happy. But there's a ton of people that are searching for content like, how do I overcome my phobia? And I made a video that is about me overcoming my bee phobia by me doing exposure therapy on myself with bees. And that video has been a video that people approach me about all the time. And they're like, I've used this video in a class. or I'm a therapist and I showed this video to a patient to help them understand
没有人会去搜索与汉·索罗和幸福心理学相关的内容。但是有成千上万的人在搜索诸如“我该如何克服恐惧症”之类的内容。我制作了一个视频，讲述我是如何通过对自己进行蜜蜂暴露疗法来克服蜜蜂恐惧症的。那个视频成为了人们经常找我谈论的一个视频。他们会说：“我在课堂上用过这个视频。”或者“我是一名治疗师，我把这个视频展示给病人，以帮助他们理解——”
what we're going to be doing. There's someone who message me on YouTube and they're like, I have a B-phobia and I looked up how to overcome your phobia and I had no idea there's a video out there about overcoming my exact phobia and this has been so helpful. So not creating content
我们将要做什么。有人在YouTube上给我发消息说：“我有蜜蜂恐惧症，我查过如何克服恐惧症，我根本不知道竟然有一个视频专门讲如何克服我这种确切的恐惧症，这太有帮助了。”所以，不要去创作那些只关注制作价值的内容，
that's about production value but creating content that helps people. Those are the two videos that helped me to learn that less in that I think are the most memorable. My least successful and probably one of my most successful videos. And how does social media play a role in this?
而是要去创作能够真正帮助人们的内容。正是这两段视频帮助我吸取了这个教训，我认为它们是最难忘的。我表现最差的视频，以及我最成功的视频之一。社交媒体在其中扮演了什么角色？
I know some consider YouTube baby social media, but it's a big part of your brand, if you will. Can you talk about how you use that channel as to promote your videos? Yeah, well, I think every platform has its strengths. So YouTube is really good at helping people to discover visual-based content that answers questions,
我知道有些人把YouTube视为某种社交媒体，但如果你愿意的话，它是你个人品牌的重要组成部分。你能谈谈你是如何利用那个频道来推广你的视频的吗？嗯，我认为每个平台都有它的优势。YouTube非常擅长帮助人们发现基于视觉的内容，这些内容能够解答问题，
and also YouTube channels are great at creating a sense of community around a cause. But YouTube isn't necessarily the best platform for immediate conversations or conversations around an event like this. So that's something that Twitter is much better at. So I use Twitter to try to make sure that psychology is being represented
而且YouTube频道在围绕某个事业营造社区感方面也非常出色。但YouTube不一定是最适合即兴对话或围绕像这样的活动进行对话的平台。这就是Twitter表现更好的地方。所以我用Twitter来确保心理学能够体现在——
in the big issues that are being discussed today. And so some people find me on Twitter, and they might look up my other content and find the psych show, or they might not. And it gets back to that idea of giving psychology away and being on platforms and making sure that psychology is represented on those platforms. And so, I mean, this is kind of my call-to-action part of the video.
今天正在讨论的重大议题中。所以有些人会在Twitter上找到我，他们可能会去浏览我的其他内容并找到《心理学秀》，也可能不会。这就回到了那个理念：普及心理学，活跃在各个平台上，并确保心理学在这些平台上有一席之地。所以，我的意思是，这差不多就是我视频中的行动号召部分。
If this was a YouTube video, and we're getting close to the end, this would be my call to action, where I would say, in addition to clicking on the like below and subscribing and sharing with your friends, what I say to you all is, like, we need your voices out there on these different platforms, because there's a very specific niche that I know and I can speak to, and there's my life experience, and there's my interest, and I can speak to those things. And that's going to resonate with a certain group of people. But I can't speak to everything. There's a lot of stuff out there. Just like looking through the program book, I was like,
如果这是一个YouTube视频，而我们又接近尾声了，这就是我的行动号召环节，我会说：除了点击下方的点赞、订阅并与你的朋友分享之外，我对在座各位说的是，我们需要你们的声音出现在这些不同的平台上。因为我知道并能谈论一个非常特定的细分领域，那是我的生活经验和兴趣所在，我可以谈论这些事情。这会与特定的一群人产生共鸣。但我无法谈论所有事情。外面有太多东西了。就像浏览项目手册时，我想：
I don't know anything about any of this stuff. And there are so many other people out there who know so much about psychology that need to give it away. And there's people who have life experiences and stories that people need to hear, and we need to give that stuff away, because there's never going to be enough of us. So that's my call to action, is getting people to find a platform that resonates with them that matches where they are right now in their careers. And think about the stuff that you know really well, that you talk about every single day, that you have a ton of examples for, ensure that with an audience that you never see. I think that's the magic of what we can do with these different platforms is we can scale up the work that we do. Like in a week,
我对这里面的任何东西一无所知。外面有那么多对心理学了如指掌的人，需要把这些知识分享出去。有些人拥有人们需要听到的生活经验和故事，我们需要把这些东西分享出去，因为我们永远不会有足够的人手。这就是我的行动号召：让人们找到一个能与自己产生共鸣、契合他们目前职业生涯所在阶段的平台。去想想那些你非常精通、每天都在谈论、能随口说出大量例子的事情，并确保与你从未谋面的受众分享这些。我认为这就是我们在这些不同平台上所能做的事情的魔力所在：我们可以扩大我们所做工作的规模。比如在一周内，
I see what? Between 20 and 30 patients, I have a few grad students that I work with, a postdoc, and consult with the other clinics, not the other clinics, but the other clinicians at Columbia and stuff like that. That's a very small, narrow impact. But if you take the stuff that you know so well and find a way to share it online with an audience you never reach, well, now you can reach thousands, thousands and thousands of people. So that's what I try to do with different social media platforms, and that's what I hope all of you will consider doing as well. So what advice do you have for a first time or who is like wants to share what they know with the world? How do they get it started? Figure out what it is that you know so well and come so
我能看多少个病人？大概20到30个之间，我有几个带的研究生，一个博士后，还要和其他诊所——不是其他诊所，而是哥伦比亚大学的其他临床医生等进行咨询。这是一个非常小、非常狭窄的影响力。但如果你把你如此精通的知识拿出来，找到一种方法在网上与你从未接触过的受众分享，那么你就可以接触到成千上万、成千上万的人。这就是我尝试在不同的社交媒体平台上做的事情，这也是我希望在座各位也会考虑去做的事情。那么，对于一个初学者，或者一个想要与世界分享自己所知的人，你有什么建议？他们该如何开始？弄清楚什么是你如此精通、如此信手拈来，以至于你总是和同事、病人、朋友谈论的事情，然后试着寻找最适合该内容的媒介。比如，YouTube并不适合所有事情。YouTube非常适合简单、在某种程度上有视觉或情感冲击力的信息。YouTube不适合就心理学中的“可重复性危机”展开复杂的讨论。也许是的。也许你是一个对这方面非常了解、能够简单明了地谈论它的人。但我不是。我认为这更适合播客这样的形式，因为那是两个同事之间的讨论。所以播客和音频非常适合——
easily to you that you always talk about with colleagues, with patients, with friends, and then try to find media that best matches that. Like, YouTube is not good for everything. YouTube is great for simple messages that are visual or emotional in some way. YouTube's not great for having a complicated discussion about the replication crisis in psychology. Like, maybe it is. Maybe you're someone who knows that really well and you can simply talk to it. I'm not. That's something that I think is better suited for maybe like a podcast, where it's a discussion between two colleagues. So podcasts and audio, they're great for
讨论、辩论和对话。而文字形式则是真正探讨复杂想法的最佳媒介。它也是最容易入门的形式。所以对于任何想要开始尝试的人，我想说的是：想想你在哪里可以学会如何写得一手好文章。因为尽管我制作视频，但我所有的视频都是从剧本开始的。而我从中学到的一切关于写剧本的知识，都可以追溯到多年前我在博客上学到的写作知识。所以，我认为有一本书叫做《科学写作者手册》（The Science Writers Handbook），
discussions and debates and dialogue. And then the written form is a medium that I think is the best for really complicated ideas. It's also the easiest one to break into. So for anyone who's looking to just get started, I would say think about where can you learn to write really well. Because even though I make videos, all of my videos start with a script. And everything I learned about writing a script comes back to what I learned about writing many years ago on my blog. So there's, I think there's this book, The Science Writers Handbook. and that book is fantastic for learning how to write and how to communicate science with the public. That would be one I'd pick up.
那本书对于学习如何写作以及如何向公众传达科学知识简直棒极了。那会是我推荐阅读的一本书。你可以找一个也许能让你去客座发文的博客，那是起步的好方法。人们总是在寻找稿件贡献，或者你也可以自己开一个博客。这基本上是免费且容易做到的。所以我想说：找到你的信息，找到正确的媒介，然后把它做好，并从其他人那里获取反馈。当我说反馈时，我的意思是那些可能不是心理学家的人。我认为我的妻子就是我生活的执行制片人。
And to either find a blog that you might be able to do a guest post at, that's a great way to get started. People are always looking for contributions or starting your own blog. It's kind of like free and easy to do. So I would say find your message, find the right medium, and then get good at it and get feedback from other people. And when I mean feedback, I mean people who probably aren't psychologists. I consider my wife to be the executive producer of my life.
所以我总是向她推销我想创作的内容的想法。她不是心理学家。如果她竖起大拇指向下，我就不会制作那个内容。但如果她喜欢，那我就觉得：我这次抓对了。因为如果她喜欢，如果她对它感兴趣，她就代表了我想接触的目标受众。所以，去征求那些并非从事心理学行业的人的反馈吧。是的。我觉得你说的这一点真的很好，并不是每个人都必须走YouTube这条路。
And so I always pitch her ideas for content that I want to create. And she's not a psychologist. And if she gives it the thumb down, I don't make that content. But if she likes it, then I'm like, I'm on to something here. Because if she likes it, if she's interested in it, she represents that audience that I want to get in touch with. So get feedback from people who aren't in psychology. Yeah. I think it's really great that you're saying that it's not everyone has to take the avenue of doing YouTube.
比如，如果有人在镜头前感到不自在，不想（你知道的）购买设备并学习如何使用它，他们还有其他方式与世界分享他们所知道的。我认为你分享这一点非常有力量。是的。有些故事我想分享，但YouTube并不是最好的媒介。同样的，任何非常复杂的讨论，我进行过非常复杂的讨论。我在YouTube上并没有取得太大的成功。
Like if someone is not comfortable on camera, they don't want to, you know, buy the technology and learn how to use it. There are other ways to share what they know with the world. I think that's really powerful that you share that. Yeah. And there's some stories that I want to share that YouTube is not the best medium for that. Again, anything that's a really complicated discussion, I have a really complicated discussion. I haven't had much success to doing that on YouTube.
所以在某些时候，当我有了想法时，我会想：好吧，这个其实作为播客效果会好得多。让我看看把这个传达给公众的最佳方式是什么。所以，是的，考虑到你所处的阶段以及你作为心理学传播者所学到的技能，去思考你想要什么以及什么才是最佳匹配。因此我不确定这一点——你现在还做播客吗，还是只做视频？不再是我自己的了。
So there are some times where I get ideas and I'm like, okay, this is actually much better as a podcast. Let me see what would be the best way to get this out to the public. So, yeah, thinking about what you want and what's the best match for that, given where you are too and the skills that you've learned as a psychology communicator. So I'm not sure of this. Do you still do podcasts as well, is the video? Not my own.
我不再有自己的播客了。在做了大约75期之后，它差不多慢慢淡出了。但我有时还会出现在其他播客节目中。那么你认为“心理学秀”未来会走向何方？你对它有什么宏伟计划？继续制作视频是其中之一。我是一位新爸爸，家里有一个一岁的孩子。她太棒了。
I don't have my own podcast anymore. I kind of slowly died after about 75 episodes. But I do sometimes appear on other podcasts. So where do you see the psych show going in the future? What are your big plans for it? Keep making videos is one. I'm a new dad, and I've got a one-year-old at home. She's amazing.
我爱她。但她也喜欢一大早醒来。而我到了晚上非常困倦。
I love her. But she also likes to wake up really early in the morning. And then I am very sleepy at night. and I used to make most of my content late at night, and I don't have that time anymore. So part of my struggle right now is trying to figure out how do I continue with the day job, as well as keeping the YouTube channel alive.
我过去大部分的内容都是在深夜创作的，而我现在没有那个时间了。所以我现在面临的挣扎之一，就是试图弄清楚如何在兼顾日常工作的同时，还能让YouTube频道维持下去。
So that's something I'm trying to figure out is how do I more efficiently, faster, in a more sustainable way, create videos? So that's one thing I'm trying to figure out. So hopefully you will just keep seeing videos. But the thing that I really, the thing I'm struggling with that I want to take my channel into the future is creating more of a sense of community. So 90% of my viewers come from people who search for content. They find my video, they watch it, and then they never come back again.
所以这是我正在努力解决的问题：如何以更高效率、更快、更可持续的方式制作视频？这是我正在摸索的一点。所以希望你们能继续看到视频。但我真正纠结的、想要推动我的频道走向未来的事情，是营造更多的社区感。因为90%的观众都来自于搜索内容的网民。他们找到了我的视频，观看了它，然后就再也没有回来过。
And that's great for helping people solve a problem that they might have. But again, I think about that middle school kid. I think about me in middle school. And to search for a question related to psychology, you still kind of need to know about psychology. So what I'm trying to figure out is how do I create more of a sense of community where people come and they stay because the content is in some way resonating with them and they're interacting with other people who are also on the channel. So I want to create more of a sense of community that celebrates psychology. So I'm trying to figure out how to best do that.
这对于帮助人们解决他们可能遇到的问题来说很好。但是，再次强调，我想到了那个中学时的孩子。我想到了中学时的自己。要想搜索与心理学相关的问题，你其实还是需要对心理学有所了解。所以我现在正试图弄清楚的是：如何营造更强的社区感，让人们来到这里并留下来，因为内容在某种程度上与他们产生了共鸣，而且他们还在与其他同样在该频道上的观众互动。所以我希望营造一个更多地庆祝心理学的社区感。所以我正在寻找做到这一点的最佳方法。
The other thing that's on my wish list that I hope in the next two years I get to do is I want to make a short film. So I want to make like a two, three minute video that I'm not going to give away my idea in case someone else does it. But it's in a topic related to mental health. and I want to show people what it's like to have this thing. And it's a thing that I treat, and it's also a thing that I've experienced and I've received treatment for in the past. So it's something I really want to talk about. And I want to show.
在我的愿望清单上还有另一件事，我希望在未来两年内能够实现，那就是我想拍一部短片。我想拍一个两到三分钟的视频——我不会透露我的想法，以防别人抢先拍了。但它是关于心理健康相关的主题的。我想向人们展示患有这种病症是什么感觉。这是我治疗过的一种病，也是我过去曾亲身经历过并接受过治疗的一种病。所以这是我很想谈论的事情。我想把它展现出来。
Because you can read a description, but I want to bring it to life, what it's like to live and breathe with this thing. But that's a short film, and it's going to take time, and it's going to take people, and it's going to take resources. So one day, I'll have that. Sounds wonderful. I can't wait to see what happens. happens with the psych show and maybe more other psych brands.
因为你可以阅读一段文字描述，但我想把它带入现实，展现出带着这个东西生活和呼吸到底是什么感觉。但这毕竟是一部短片，它需要时间，需要人员，还需要资源。总有一天，我会把它做出来。听起来太棒了。我迫不及待地想看看“心理学秀”会有什么发展，也许还有更多其他的心理学品牌。
We'll see. Thank you so much for joining us. Thanks for having me. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit Speakingof Psychology.org to view more episodes and to find resources
我们拭目以待。非常感谢你加入我们。谢谢你邀请我。《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中还包括其他许多精彩播客，例如探讨最新、最激动人心的心理学研究进展的《APA期刊对话》（APA journals dialogue），以及关于心理学实践的《进度记录》（progress notes）。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们的播客。你也可以访问 Speakingof Psychology.org 来查看更多剧集并寻找我们讨论的主题相关的资源。
on the topics we discuss. Caitlin Luna for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是为美国心理学协会报道的凯特琳·卢纳。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。